[Music]
so I thought I'd uh chat a little bit
about the human desire for intimacy
what is intimacy
what fidelity of closeness are we
referring to and we talked about having
an intimate moment with someone to know
someone so completely to be seen by them
and to see them fully to be felt
and to feel the other person intimacy is
a kind of nakedness beyond measure
intimacy is a glimpse of what it's like
when we let our guard down
intimacy is to be radically open
radically vulnerable absolutely exposed
naked and trembling
before the other intimacy is a moment in
which to become one so to speak
a space opens up a cosmology of two
shaped like a heart
Martin Buber refers to the space that
opens up between two people who love
each other he calls it the between the
between is the intersubjective right and
the intersubjective is where God lives
[Music]
intimacy is the ultimate act of cosmic
reassurance it is the existential
feeling of every little thing is going
to be alright intimacy is to see
yourself reflected in absolute empathy
in the iris of your lover's eye it is
feeling yourself being felt and accepted
fully by your beloved intimacy is when
the hairs of the back of your neck stand
up
intimacy is a musical skin orgasm and
aesthetic orgasm what the French call
free zone intimacy is to feel safe
intimacy is to feel held intimacy is
with Joseph Campbell referred to as a
womb with a view intimacy is when you
well up and you feel the tears coming on
you don't cry because something is sad
you cry because something is more
beautiful than you expected it to be
intimacy is when we find out the truth
but they call cattle Epps's a sense of
certainty from which nothing can
dislodge us this is intimacy and it is
grand